please say well I don't know about that
dude in the tones described below amused
I don't know about that
dude
sad well I don't know about that dude
very
sad I don't know about that
dude in response to someone saying that
Wonka wasn't a good
movie well I don't know about that dude
that's a good one in response to being
dared to go down a creepy staircase into
a dark basement in a condemned
home I don't know about that
dude finding a dut in the toilet and
being tempted to eat it oh God have you
ever done that no I've eaten nothing
from the toilet you've eaten nothing
from the toilet that's right have
you even things that would be better if
they were a little wet